our next guest uh
who has been a
terribly fun listen and watch
on twitter uh and around his business of
football
uh podcast former packers executive mr
andrew brandt joins us
on the mercedes-benz vans line joining
us now
mr andrew brandt what's going on
hey ryan good to be with you i felt like
i was eavesdropping into some uh
some cocktail hour with rich eyes you
know what was going on there well what
in the breaks in the breaks so just to
give you some some contact uh context
during the breaks
went on peacock on the tv version of it
uh they they replaced some some uh
former greatest hits things and that was
with him and craig kilbourne one day
just you know mixing up some martinis
and having a little martini hour here on
the show
yeah i get it ryan it's good to be with
you i met you first
when you were coming out of college and
i represented a guy named ricky williams
oh yeah
who was in his junior year at the espn
college football award so we were all
down in orlando
and uh
then of course he was ready to come out
and he decided last minute he was going
to stay in another year
um
but anyway yeah i represented ricky for
a while before he fired me to go to
master p
oh
yeah that was a time that was a time i
watched ricky on bill maher the other
night
yeah yeah i thought that was interesting
those two were two peas in a pod
together uh yeah well now ricky of
course is mainstream when 20 years ago
he was out there you know that's how the
world's changed yeah definitely i mean
uh the idea that a guy would leave the
game because he couldn't uh test uh to
now you know
where the world's heading so yeah i
the business right side of everything
that 20 years ago was you were shamed
you were looked upon as being shameful
for for something like that
yeah i mean i talk about in my teaching
and my my talking is about two areas of
sports that have become completely
normalized
that
5 10 certainly 20 years ago were
completely taboo
and that number one is marijuana and
number two is sports betting
not only is sports betting allowed
because of the supreme court a few years
ago but it is embraced
you know back in the day
you had players just kicked out of the
leagues pete rhodes still is not back in
baseball
you had tony romo couldn't even go to a
fantasy football convention because it
was at a casino
i mean the way they've embraced sports
betting i just continue to shake my head
it is part and parcel of sports
from the business side right now
where do you think that shift happened
was it just ultimately when they saw
the states legalizing it and they
in the nfl saw their bottom line uh you
know just just being able to explode
because of it or where did the shift
ultimately change for you andrew well a
couple things i think obviously the
legal side the nfl and all the leagues
fought this for seven years until they
lost and i always wondered do they
really want to lose or they want to win
because if they lose
it's in place and the values of these
franchises are going to rise
significantly
what they wanted of course was a federal
solution
not the state by state patchwork which
we have now right but i think two things
grease the skids ryan number one
the embrace of fantasy
not only season long fantasy where you
show up at the beginning of the year and
draft your favorite players with your
buddies
now it's daily fantasy starting 2015
when fanduel and draftkings bombarded
the world with their
ads and their promotions and it became
mainstream and the league accepted it
and embraced it because like hey you're
not betting on the teams
you're having fun on these players
so once they embrace fantasy and realize
what an incredible fan engagement tool
that was
the only next step is real gambling
and the second thing that lured i think
all the leagues to gambling is the lore
of las vegas
it is a untapped market i think still
and you're running out of markets right
these leagues with 30 32 teams are
running out of big time markets
which are entertainment capitals
so once the nhl actually made the first
move
it was only a matter of time and of
course the raiders went there and now
all-star games are going there drafts
are going there i think combines
there you go so here we are
yeah it's it's been a an evolution
since i met you that night in orlando uh
to where we're at now
uh that's for sure not only on a
professional but uh personal level as
as well too the um the business side of
it
especially around the broadcasting
aspect right we just heard word that
troy ichman looks like he's going to be
moving from fox to espn for for monday
night football
tony romo a few years back signed the
deal
around 1 million dollars a game to call
football games right this is more money
than he'll have ever been paid
as a um as a player what what's driving
this it's it's it's the tv money it's
the tv rights i get it but
is it sustainable for for networks to to
pay this kind of money for guys who
essentially sit up there and just kind
of tell you what you just saw
yeah i mean i think that's a that's a
healthy debate ryan because obviously
i know everyone says the same thing you
don't turn on games for announcers
but in the scheme of things if you look
at owners gm's
before you get to players
probably all
broadcasters are close to players
compared to no one turns it on to watch
owners no one turns on watch gm's
but i think the issue you mentioned
briefly as you led into the question
the money
allocated towards nfl programming is
beyond anyone's expectations
i mean i continue to shake my head it
was six months ago
the nfl locked in deals they're done
it's over 110 billion dollars between
espn fox nbc cbs
and amazon for the next 11 12 years 110
billion dollars it's mind-blowing
mind-blowing
to the point where ratings don't even
matter you know we people talk about
well this week they got this rating this
week they got who cares i mean ratings
are irrelevant now
because they've made the deals
and if the ratings keep going up then
it's the networks who end up looking
like they got the good deal rather than
the nfl
so i guess my point is when you're
spending pick a number 20 billion
at espn or fox or cbs or nbc
what's 15 million a year to a
broadcaster you know it's like that's
just part of the program it's like
you know my negotiations i'll lay in on
my negotiations with the packers i'm
like listen i'm managing 150 million
dollar player payroll here
well i deserve a percentage of that you
know like if i was an asset manager at a
company
i'd get you know one two three percent
of that
so you're all it's all in scale when you
negotiate these deals
uh the aaron rodgers conversation you
have always been a guy that
that we go to with with this with this
conversation right uh you you signed him
back in the day you've been uh kind of
been on the ground floor watching this
all play out a year ago
uh you felt like there's no way if he
decides to come back he's going anywhere
else this year you've been a little more
hesitant you thought maybe something may
happen where do you think we stand right
now and and do you think we'll hear
something soon enough
yeah i mean i listen i try not to be
wishy-washy i've for two years i've said
okay 2021 he's back there's nowhere to
go packers aren't trading him he's not
going to retire
and that happened even though a lot of
people thought he was so upset he'd
never show up
2022 i have maintained
realizing i could be wrong that i think
this is the separation point between him
and the packers
a couple reasons i'll just keep going
back to
draft night 2020
where everyone's in their basement the
covent draft
i just remember seared images in my mind
of brian good accounts and matt laflore
smiling ear to ear that they had just
traded up
to get jordan love
now with aaron we sat back and waited
and we didn't want to take a quarterback
but he's staring us in the face and we
fell in our lap
with jordan love they went up and got
him
and i just don't think they got him for
him to sit three years
maybe certainly not one year
but i thought two years i just have
thought two years
so here we are now
and of course they didn't expect aaron
to have two mvp years but we keep
hearing about oh you know aaron doesn't
know yet doesn't i'm like if he wanted
to come back and everything was
copacetic with the packers why why what
are we doing here
like what are we doing
this idea that they hired his old coach
well his old coach coached him when he
was a young quarterback
which would be good for jordan love
or this idea that he's getting along
better with the front office well if
he's getting along better with front
office then let's go what are we waiting
for
so i i guess you know i'm trying to say
this is why i think
there'll be a separation and the
separation could be a trade it could be
retirement
that's secondary
but i just as long this as it continues
to take longer
i'm sort of staying with what i've felt
all along that this is a separation
point
well it's been very very interesting
around what that's going to be and he's
you know his appearances on the pat
mcafee show have made it even more
interesting in terms of what he's going
to do
let's say they they make the decision uh
to
to coincide with one another and get it
done
what kind of contract do you think
he's going to want
uh and one that the packers are going to
be able to give because of the salary
cap situation that they're in right now
well
if he stays i think it's
again i'm going to be maybe i'm wrong
again a year from now but if he stays
i say to one year
what people don't realize is a year ago
he negotiated a deal where he's got an
out i thought maybe he was going to try
to get an out after this year he got it
out after next year
and i guess my question is why would he
give that up
why would he give up an ability to be a
free agent and pick his team and pick
his money
a year from now
so he could get 50 million guarantee i
mean listen i don't
i don't know why he would give that up
i'm looking at it from the player point
of view
i think that's more valuable than money
i do
um
so i guess what i'm saying is they would
bonus out a big bonus this year
have these dummy years in the contract
which all these teams are doing
to prorate the bonus over a bunch of
years
and get it done but as you've noted from
my twitter ryan past few weeks
but i think this cap stuff from the
public point of view is is way overrated
people like me in my former position are
hired to figure it out
just like coaches coach and gm's manage
cap managers
manage the cap so
i said this in a tweet last week i said
fans and media
worry a lot more about teams caps than
the teams do
they'll figure it out well
that's the thought i had around all this
too was the fact that
like this team didn't all of a sudden go
oh my gosh we're this much over the cap
they knew it going into it they had a
plan in place and they've already
started to execute it right they've cut
about half of that 50 plus million
dollars off the cap and if they
renegotiate rogers if he's able to come
back i mean that's 46 million dollars in
dead money that that goes away and is
redistributed other places
exactly and i don't know what you know
maybe the darius smith goes maybe
randall cobb goes i mean there are a lot
of things they can do and you're right
you're so right these teams have plans
and frankly i don't believe
brian good [ __ ] when he says yeah we'll
just wait for aaron and figure it out no
they've figured it out
and part of me thinks they know what
aaron's going to do
uh
you know they have figured it out that
that's what their job is to do and all
these teams you know they they don't
wake up in february and say oh boy what
do we do right i'm sure there's the
conversations with dave dunn aaron's
agent has been ongoing uh if and when uh
so when this comes down to it uh and
because of when the league season
uh when the new league season starts you
got to have it already because you got
to be below the cap so it makes sense
speaking of
agents and you were in this business
i wanted to ask you this question about
lamar jackson in the juxtaposition with
him and kyler murray because kyler
murray's agent has made some comments of
late trying to get him a bigger uh a big
extension like the likes of patrick
mahomes and josh allen where lamar
jackson who is a mvp who has gone into
extended stays into the playoffs and is
there franchise quarterback
is going on his fifth year option
without a a contract in place where do
you think in terms of those two things
um
whether an agent is doing a disservice
to kyler or is it a disservice to lamar
not having
well i think we can answer the lamar
thing within the kyler answer kyler uh
i'm guessing what happened i'm pretty
sure what happened
is his three year period came up so for
people who don't know
the cba requires three years in the
league before you can renegotiate
so he finishes the season
i'm sure eric burkhart his agent went to
the cardinals said okay three years is
up we played on this crappy rookie
contract you've been getting this
incredible value
time to do a big deal
and the cardinals maybe in some weight
or shape said we'd like to wait
and maybe it's way more into the east
offseason maybe it's wait another year
or whatever
and i believe that stung murray and his
agent and so his agent puts it out on
twitter
basically show me the money and now
we've got a standoff
last year two of the three quarterbacks
in that position did not get deals
the one that did was josh allen the one
that didn't was mayfield and jackson and
the ravens
um
unlike what appears to be happening with
murray
jackson and mayfield
did not make a big deal about it
uh i don't think murray is going to be
as quiet
so i think they've got a problem there
now jackson didn't do a deal we don't
know why people speculate because he
didn't have an agent he's doing it by
himself or he's using his mom or some
advisor
i'm not sure that's you know accurate
there's obviously reasons involved but
if the ravens wanted to do a deal
i don't think the fact that he didn't
have a traditional agent would have
stopped that
maybe if he had a traditional agent
there'd be more
pressure on the ravens to do the deal
uh and maybe it would have resulted in a
little bit more of a
adverse stance like murray is taking
so it's interesting yeah it's it's
incredibly interesting and uh
and we really appreciate your time
andrew brandt everybody former packers
executive and um
podcast
business of sports andrew good to talk
to you again i've been i've been hoping
for this every time i hosted rich's show
to get you on and talk about all this
stuff it was good to hear from you again
thanks for joining us
always good to be with you ryan i know
people are tweeting me about the
newsletter too so upper newsletter now
just go to andrewdashbrandt.com
and i'll get you that newsletter sign up
i'm on it i'm going to get on it i need
to
i appreciate you andrew
thanks ryan
andrew brandt everybody former nfl
executive with the packers of course
as well as professor
where he teaches business of football
he's got a podcast and now a newsletter
that goes with it check that out hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here